اخر محطات خريطه الطريق التي اقررها
الرئيس التونسي قيس سعيد اي الانتخابات
التشريعيه تجرى وقع قانون الانتخابيه لاقا
انتخابات حتى ممن دعوا المسار الجديد
وايضا من المترشحين في مشاهدت عشر دوائر
تسجيل مرشح وحيد من بين هذا دائره
بالعاصمه حيث يواصل النائب الاسبق هشام
حسني حملته الانتخابيه رغم ظفره بالمقعد
النيابي اليا ويقول ان غياب المنافسين يجب
ان لا يلغي التفاعل المباشر
[موسيقى]
انك لابد انك تبلغ البرنامج ثلاثه
السياسي يتنافس في هذه الانتخابات
1058 مترشحا على 100.61 مقعدا في البرلمان
وفق قانون انتخابيا جديد قائما على
الافراد بدل القوائم الحزبيه التي اعتاد
الناخبون الاختيار من بينها في السابق
فيما سجلت عشر دوائر انتخابيه الترشح شخص
واحد كما شاهدت سبع دوائر انتخابيه في
الخارج غيابا للمترشحين
وارجع مراقبه الشان الانتخابي ضعف الاقبال
على الترشح الى مقاطعه الاحزاب السياسيه
الفاعله واعتبار الاتحاد التونسي للشغل
الانتخابات المقبله بلا لون ولا طعام
اضافه الى القانون الانتخابيه الجديده
الذي وضع شروطا وصفها البعض بالتعجيزيه
كضروره جمع التزكيات وغياب التمويل
العمومي كما ان الانتقادات طالت ايضا عددا
كبيرا من المترشحين الذين لم يعرف لهم
نشاطا سياسي سابق
ونتيجه لكل ما سبق يقول لبعض ان المنافسه
ستختصر على دعم الرئيس ومشروعه وان نسب
المشاركه ستكون عاملا مهما في تقييم
المسار الذي انتهجه سعيد
وشرعايته شعبيه
اعتقد الانتخابات ستقتصر على انصار الرئيس
وبالتالي هنا ومن ما سيفقدها اي منافسه
على الميدان او حتى في صناديق الاقتراع
لان الانتخابات في النهايه يجب ان تكون
بين المتنافسين واغلب المرشحين هم
يتنافسون على ربما التقرب من الرئيس قيسي
سعيد
ايمصر قانون الانتخابيه على اجراء دور
ثاني في حال عدم الحصول على الاغلبيه
المطلقه وهو ما سيطيل الزمن الانتخابي
ويبقى العمل بالاجراءات الاستثنائيه التي
يعتبرها الرئيس مخرج للبلاد من الوضع الذي
انزلقت اليه
ويصفها خصومه بالانقلاب المكتمل الاركان
قد تشكل الانتخابات التشريعيه محطه فاصله
للرئيس قيس سعيد لاستكمال تصوره لاصلاح
الاوضاع في تونس لكن معارضيه يرونها خطوه
اخرى لتكريس نظام الفرد الذي يراقبه
برلمان منزوع الصلاحيات سيف الدين الجزيره
تونس